هذه الزياره الى المملكه العربيه السعوديه
هي المحطه الخارجيه الاولى لامير البلاد
الشيخ مشعل الاحمد الصباح منذ تولي الحكم
في البلاد منتصف ديسمبر الماضي وتاتي بعد
انقضاء فتره الحداد التي اعلنتها الكويت
في اعقاب وفاه الامير الراحل الشيخ نواف
الاحمد واختيار السعوديه كمحطات اولى
لزياره الامير يجسد المكانه التي تحضى بها
المملكه لدى الكويت والكويتيين ويؤكد
العلاقات المتاصله بين البلدين سواء على
الصعيد الرسمي او الشعبي ويبحث الجانبان
في هذه الزياره التي تستمر ليوم واحد عددا
من الملفات والقضايا التي اصبحت تشكل
تحديات بالنسبه لامن واستقرار المنطقه
فبالاضافة
للقضايا الاقليميه والدوليه وبتولي الشيخ
مشعل الاحمد الجابر الصباح السلطه تدخل
الكويت عهدا جديدا سيكون من ركائز سياسته
الخارجيه تعزيز عمل المنظومه الخليجيه
والعلاقات مع الشقيقه الكبرى المملكه
العربيه السعوديه ودول مجلس التعاون مثلما
داب عليه الامر دوما خلال العقود الماضيه
سعد السعيدي الجزيره الكويت